peace be unto you
welcome to the Dean show I'm a two-year
host me ask you a question if I ask now
1.5 over you know what 1.7 billion
Muslims all over the globe if I asked
them do you love Jesus
none of them would hesitate and say yes
we do let me ask you they're not yet
Muslims do you love Muhammad many of you
you're gonna be--start on the same
Mohammed who is he many of them many of
you don't know about one of the most
influential Michael h-heart who talks
about in his book the 100 most
influential men throughout history he
labeled Muhammad peace be upon him
number one who was the last final
messenger sent to mankind so it's a
shame that you don't know this man but
in this short episode we're gonna be
talking about his life his biography
with the author of Jesus and the last
and final messenger prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him when we come back here
on the Dean show don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
this is the with a lot thank you for
having me on the show it's a real
pleasure and honor to be here today
thank you for being with us I kind of
got stuck there I was on some old
numbers I said 1.5 billion over 1.7
billion Muslims you're one of those
Muslims just like Jesus was one who
submits to the will of the Creator not
the creation and if I ask you do you
love Jesus what would you say absolutely
unequivocally yes I do absolutely no
hesitation no hesitation but many people
you heard now the other side of the
question we asked not yet Muslims do you
love Muhammad and a lot of people they
don't know Muhammad so we're doing this
episode so people can get to know
Muhammad that's why you wrote the book
so you put Jesus and the last and final
message tell us why this title Thank You
jazakallah khair I really admire the
work that you and the dean Cho have been
doing I think calling people to the
truth is a fantastic calling and the
reason why I did the book is for the
sake of God you know there's no other
higher purpose than serving God and and
essentially remembering the memories and
examples good examples of the prophets
including Jesus may peace be upon him
and the Prophet Muhammad SAW the law or
though I saw them and I realized that
there's a huge opportunity here when you
think about books like Harry Potter and
Lord of the Rings these are very very
popular fiction stories but there's an
even more inspiring true nonfiction
story that is very well historically
documented and it is the life of the
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu wasallam the
peace be upon him and the Prophet that
was before him was a Jesus may peace be
upon him and that is a story that a lot
of folks are familiar with they're
familiar with different versions and not
only did Jesus but Moses
they knew that there would be a last and
final messenger and it's in the
scriptures it's in the Torah and it's
also in the Bible and essentially the
prophet muhammad's allah Louis alum has
been a big inspiration in my life and I
wanted friends family and neighbors to
benefit and be inspired and have a fun
time reading this fast-paced
inspirational nonfiction story Jesus and
the last Messenger is it true what I
said now you have Michael H Hart who is
Oh a historian he went back and he
looked at all the different top figures
throughout history and he put he
mentioned you know Jesus in there he
mentions many many other great people
but he put Muhammad peace be upon him
number one is this true he did indeed
Michael Hart dead list Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu Isola may peace be upon him
as the number one most influential
figure in all of history
you know looking at folks of all
different faiths political leaders
religious leaders and I think it's very
remarkable it's very remarkable that he
did that I agree with the statement the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu they saw
him the last message last and final
messenger and prophet he was he played
so many roles he was a spiritual leader
he was the head of a nation state
he was the commander in chief he was at
the frontlines when he had to go into
conflict in the battle as a last resort
when a peaceful means it didn't work he
was a marriage counselor he was a
husband he was a father and I don't know
of very many figures historical figures
that did so many things so well they
used to say that he used to spend 1/3 of
his life for family purposes a third of
his life war prayer and a third of his
life attending to matters of the state
and so it's just phenomenal to see his
commitment and they grand amazing
inspirational impact that he's had but I
think there's an opportunity that we
have in the West and other places in the
world for folks to be introduced and for
folks that know about the story for the
story to be reinvigorated and reignited
and I actually reread many parts of the
story of the Prophet Muhammad may peace
be upon him and the Quran just so that
we can remind ourselves of all the
miracles
that occurred in his life and we should
believe in God the one and only God and
his prophets all the prophets including
Jesus and Moses and Abraham and the
Prophet Muhammad who was the last and
final messenger and the angels and the
Scriptures and if we believe in all
those things really truly remarkable
things can happen it can really solve
all of society's problems if we believe
yeah tell us Adam we know that it's not
hard to get to no problem how many peace
be upon him his life is so authentically
record he's one of the most documented
men in history I mean thee if you look
that's one of the miracles along with we
have the Quran - verbatim Word of God
which is living miracle but now were you
just fascinated writing about his life
his biography did you see miracles
inside just his day-to-day activities in
life and were you inspired now even more
does it does increase you in your Eman
we say in your faith it has indeed
increased me in my faith it has brought
me back to the faith I've I was born
Muslim but you know you go through
different levels of spirituality and in
the last few years since I started this
effort it has reinvigorated my faith and
there were a lot of miracles and the one
that you mentioned is perhaps the
greatest miracle that he had the
scripture the purified scripture that
has been unaltered for the last 14
centuries which is the Quran the book of
truth the book of God or the book of
allah subhanaw taala and but there were
many other miracles during one of the
battles it is the Battle of the trench
the his followers the Muslims were
essentially digging a big trench and
they were going to face off with the
Koresh who persecuted and opposed the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu they saw
them and the Muslims and during one of
the the scenes there was a believer a
Muslim that invited him because it was a
time of drought and hunger and and the
hunger was so bad that the Muslims and
the Prophet home of the peace be upon
had to tie stones around their stomach
to repress the hunger and the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu a Salaam had to tie
two stones to his belly because the the
hunger was so bad and so this Muslim
believer follower
came and said hey why don't you bring a
few of your friends over and we can eat
a meal together my wife has prepared
something we've slaughtered an animal
and we have some bread and so the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu has som
said come on and a basically motion to
much of the army to come with him and
when they went there this Muslim
follower was was oh my gosh I don't know
he's talking to his wife whether we're
going to have enough food to feed all
these people and the wife had complete
trust in Allah subhana Allah and the
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu wasallam
and said you know what he knows what
he's doing and one of the miracles of
the prophets Allah milk with a solemn
when food was scarce when water was
scarce through supplicating and saying
prayers to the one and only God the one
and only creator Allah the the food was
able to multiply and the water was able
to gush forth and this is very well
documented by hundreds and hundreds of
witnesses all those are witnesses there
who ate from them drink from the milk or
the water that was multiplied does
exactly exactly you know I think one of
the things not only in the Muslim
circles but Christian circles Jewish
circles all the different faiths is that
we believe in historical events be it
the Roman Empire be at the time of Jesus
Abraham and this also is history this is
history it is one of the opportunities
that we have in the West to have a
balanced approach and this is something
that a lot of us need to take a look at
but this book while it is based on
historical events it essentially tries
to focus on the inspirational
non-fiction parts of the life the
conversations the miracles the events
and so when people read it it doesn't
read like a history book it reads like
you were actually there and it's fun
people are able to read it in one
sitting in a matter of three or four
hours Jesus and the last messenger we're
gonna be back with more God will in here
to talk more about this book with the
author we'll be right back here in the
deshawn I want you to imagine you wake
up and in front of you are a bunch of
guys running around kicking a ball no
goals no lines no rules what would you
think but is that your life
surely every sport has its goal every
game has its end it has its objective it
has its rules how about life how about
our life isn't there a goal to life
isn't there a purpose an objective that
we have to reach we think so the Quran
tells us that we exist
in order to worship God and worshiping
God means knowing God as the Quran says
when the holocrons in the will insert
allure Lyuba do worship though is not
some narrow small thing its wide its
vast it encompasses everything that the
human being does everything that you do
everything that you think everything
that you feel can be done thought said
felt in a way that is either pleasing or
displeasing to God the purpose of life
is to try and do everything in a way
that God loves and God is pleased with
that is your goal back here on the Deen
show now those 1.7 plus billion Muslims
those who submit to the Creator not the
creation we love Jesus people are now
through this episode trying to get some
glimpses of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him Jesus came with the same
message that Muhammad came Muhammad came
of the same message Jesus came they all
call people to worship the one God the
one creator not the creation do good
prepare for today a judgement now people
a lot of people the reason we bring up
these miracles many people they flunk
Jesus did so many wonderful miracles you
know what I mean and he was a man of
peace you followed me so a two-fold
question we talked about one of the
miracles we have the ultimate miracle
the Quran it's the verbatim Word of God
is testable to this day but also through
examples in a prophets life we see these
miracles so is there are there any other
miracles that you can share with us and
also the other question would be like
how was he a prophet if you're talking
about these wars that he went through
because many people they know Jesus is
never fighting you know
but now Muhammad they try to discredit
him because he was in some battles yes
well you know it's very interesting that
in the early part of his prophethood and
and the Muslim community what was
forming that God the one and only
creator Allah did not give permission
for the Muslims to fight so he basically
was preaching peacefully he was leading
a good life had good character show a
good example he was very truthful he was
absolutely inspiring but he did
everything through peaceful means and it
wasn't until multiple multiple years
that the tribe of krrish persecuted and
prevented the the muslims from for
example visiting the sanctuary the Kaaba
the house that Abraham built many many
centuries ago that Allah subhana Allah
in the Quran revealed verses that gave
the Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu asylum
and the Muslims the permission to go
ahead and fight because they have been
prevented from going to the sanctuary
the house of God and from practicing
their religion openly so there's a
misperception that Islam was spread
through the sword it was spread through
good character by good examples and when
they were confronted then they were
given permission to go ahead and fight
and there's there's rules of engagement
and fighting in war
thank God I myself never been in a war
but there's a way to do everything
there's a way to do everything and and
that was one of the things that the
Prophet Muhammad SAW little'o with us
almost on your first part of your
question around miracles there are so
many miracles hold it hold it right
there we're gonna get to miracles but
isn't it ironic when you watch you know
some of these figures like you know
Alexander the Great they call him or
will you see Braveheart and you know
these people that are out there fighting
for good and they got the sword and
people are like wow this guy's amazing
he's a hero but if you look at like you
were just mentioning the earlier Muslims
were tortured just like the Christians
during Jesus's time they were tortured
they were persecuted you know they were
boycotted can you talk about this you
know and they weren't fighting for how
many years they went through the
persecution they didn't fight you know
what I mean but finally when they were
able to defend themselves they were able
to you know fight for justice and for
for the for the being able to to worship
the Creator not the creation you know
why would anybody object
that now and try to discredit the
problem Hamid peace be upon him well you
know I think sometimes when you when you
think about something that is so
spectacular and so grand and too good to
be true
you know if you have not accepted the
faith of peace you know you want to sort
of stick to what you know and what
you've been taught and it takes a great
deal of courage and being brave to go
out there and explore something for
example I'm Muslim and when I'm
confronted with a new idea it's worth
checking out to see does it hold up or
not and the proof is there for folks
that want to find out the truth so there
are many reasons why why folks try to
describe discredit the Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu iserlohn but you really have
to carefully assess the argument and see
what the motivations and intentions are
it's it's amazing that you know both of
my neighbors in California are Christian
and we have a very healthy respect with
each other they have differences of
opinion about the prophets of times past
but we have a spectacular Lee even
greater dialogue and interfaith matters
they've actually read the book and you
know we have healthy dialogue but you
really have to just understand whether
people are trying to seek the truth or
they have some other type of intention
now when you look at how many people
totally until Tali died even through
these 23 years I had one of my guests
before Islamic scholar he was talking
about about only 1,200 people in the
whole 23 years do you know what number
is that
I don't recall the the figure exactly
but that's very low compared to the
casualties that the opposition the
Koresh and their Confederates and allies
they faced very very heavy losses in
fact after the battle bothered the first
major conflict that happened between the
two sides the Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu they saw them and the
Muslims versus the Quraysh and their
allies most of the leaders of the
Quraysh died or passed away from from
their battle injuries and the Abu Sufyan
the the leader that became the leader of
the Koresh he then stepped up but he was
very unprepared for that but it is very
interesting to point that you're making
Eddie that that the the casualties were
a lot heavier on the opposition that
they were trying to oppose the Prophet
Mohammed mostly I'm talking about in
totality I think it was only two from
both sides yes I believe and it's
interesting if you
the bible for instance when the children
of Israel when they went and worshipped
the calf yes yes three thousand people
were put to death this is according to
the Bible in one day
and Moses is still not discredited he's
still considered a Messenger of God
that's just interesting interesting
let's go he ever comes yeah yeah I was
just going to say that you know finally
when not to give away the ending ending
but but close to the end the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu though so long for
a vast majority of the angles that you
look at this him and the followers the
Muslims they actually overtake they
overtook the the holiest city Makkah
through relatively peaceful means with
very little bloodshed and so I think
that that is a big big miracle and the
fact that a lot of people that opposed
him that persecuted him and the Muslims
he was incredibly merciful the example
that you're giving he had certain rights
to sort of exact justice but he let go
of the vast majority of folks he did not
hold them hostage he did not take them
prisoner there were some exceptions for
good reason but the vast majority of
people were allowed to live peacefully
they were not forced into accepting
Islam I mean that event in and of itself
is just awe-inspiring how peacefully
they overtook Makkah and how everybody
was able to to co-exist whether they
accepted the message or not that's when
they came back ten thousand strong
exactly and now you can imagine what
somebody you know would come and do in
retaliation all the abuse except for the
torture for the boycott but there was
there are very few peacefully yes you
know came in and overtook Mecca very few
human beings that have shown that type
of mercy the amount of myrrh obviously
Allah is the most merciful
he's the rahmani raheem but in terms of
human beings there are very few people
that were as merciful and generous and
kind and forgiving as the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him you talked
about that in your book absolutely there
is that we're talking about lot of this
is in the book absolutely okay it's
available you know on Amazon but what we
per back in eBook okay we're going to
talk some you know we're not done
yet we're gonna take a break I'm excited
this is one of my favorite topics we're
talking about the biography of the last
and final messenger sent to mankind
we're not excluding Jesus or Moses eh
but they were all Muslims live in Islam
and we're talking about their message
and much more here in a Deen show
back here on the D show and we're
talking to the author of Jesus and the
last and final messenger to pro Muhammad
peace be upon him
no Muslim is a Muslim if you exclude
Jesus you can have a one-way ticket to
the Hellfires of Muslims this true
Allah is the master of the Day of
Judgment but we do need to accept all
his prophets otherwise you know we're
going to lower our chances of getting
the ultimate reward of paradise exclude
one exclude them all we accept them all
we accept Moses Jesus Abraham the last
the final messenger because they all
came with the same message they call
people to have a loving relationship
with the one who created you the one
you're going to return back to and
hopefully at the end of the show when we
ask people you know do you love Muhammad
they say you know what I'm so intrigued
by what you guys would say I'm gonna at
least get to know them and then
hopefully they'll fall in love with them
as over close to 1 1 point 7 plus
billion all over the world have now
miracles people love these miracles we
have the living miracle the Quran we've
talked about that other shows but let's
talk about another miracle there at the
Battle the trench preparing to defend
themselves the Quraysh they're coming on
the attack and now you know the spirits
are kind of low they're digging the
trench they work it there's a huge
boulder the prophet saw some strikes at
three times talked about this yes it is
also a documented fact it's based on
accounts that have been well preserved
over time there's a very precise chain
of narration that has happened over the
last 14 centuries and these are called
sahih hadith these are examples and well
authenticated stories about the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu as I saw them so
they were trying to dig this trench and
you know some of the soil was fairly
tough to break away and one of the
miracles that the Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu a seldom had was that he was
able to tap or strike or pour water over
these very difficult rocks to to remove
and on one such occasion there was a
very big rock boulder and he struck it
and from there appeared several
lightning bolts and the Muslims asked
Jaros Allah law what is this what is the
meaning of this and he said that that
the Muslims have been granted several
lands that they would overtake in the
future including Syria including
modern day back then Persia now it's
called Iran and several other lines
Byzantium and so there were really four
lands that were mentioned there and it
came to pass shortly after he passed
away that the Muslims over took all
those lands if you take a look at 14
centuries ago there abouts the Muslims
in very short order conquered all those
lands and again this is a historically
documented prophecy in miracle the event
that happened in the lightning bolts his
interpretation and that played itself
out on the example of Persia for example
and other lands such as Byzantium and
Abyssinia which is called Matt
modern-day Ethel Pia the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu I seldom had the
courage to write letters to these very
powerful leaders some of them knew about
him others didn't and you know the
leader of Persia when he got the letter
he ripped it up into bits he was so
angry he considered himself a stuff for
Allah to be God and we know that that's
not the case and he actually sent some
people to Yemen which was under his
control to say arrest this man the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu asylum and
when those people actually arrived at
the Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu asylums
place he saw them and he saw that they
had you know very big mustaches and they
had shaved their beard and the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him was exactly
he had he had a beard he shaved his
mustache and they exchanged sort of
comments about you know what the
situation is and he said why don't you
come back some you know to the next day
and so he came back the next day the the
people from Yemen and the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu lolol had actually
received information from angel jibreel
angel Jibril is the same angel that came
to all the prophets to Moses to Abraham
to Jesus and to the last and final
messenger and he gave him news that the
Emperor of Persia had been slain had
been murdered at the hands of his very
own son the son of the emperor of persia
and the prophet mohammed so long ago
this home conveyed this to the two
people from yemen and said why don't you
take this back and let them know about
it and here are some here's some gold
you know to take back is a good gesture
and these two people went back the
soldiers went back and told the
ruler of Yemen about what the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu those elements said
and they were just flabbergasted how
could somebody make that statement they
said well let's just wait and actually
shortly thereafter a messenger came from
Persia and brought news that in fact the
emperor of Persia had been slain and
that the son of that late Emperor was
asking for their allegiance and then
they realized that how could somebody
sitting hundreds of miles away know
about this event happening and so then
the ruler of Yemen and all of his
dignitaries the people that reported in
to him accepted Islam and sent message
back and the prophet salallahu alaihe
salam sent forth muslims to help them
understand more about Islam and many of
the people in Yemen were in fact
Christian and they followed suit and
also accepted Islam so that's and
there's many many stories I would
encourage folks that are Muslim that are
Christian that are Jew to take a look at
the story to have fun and to learn the
truth about this historic historical
account is a very fast paced
book and they can learn about all these
stories there's a lot that's packed in
there but it's done in a way that it
doesn't feel dense yeah there was no
instant messenger no email no it's not
happened there's no self that's right
and this is a journey they'll take you
that probably about close to two months
exactly he's getting this information
exactly you know this is a miracle in
itself one more one more yeah just give
it a condensed version bounty hunters
coming after him yes this guy's an
experienced horse rider he's sinking in
the sand yes talk to us about this
absolutely so the context around this is
that the Quraysh had sort of had it at a
certain point and they said to
themselves like we need to deal with
this prophet muhammad sallahu a solemn
character and so they conspired to
essentially get younger a men to all
hold it's unthinkable but hold weapons
and essentially take the life of the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu at iserlohn
and so the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him wasn't at that meeting but the
angel jibreel basically relayed this
information of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him although he wasn't
anywhere close to the meeting and a las
planas Allah the one and only creator
God gave the Prophet Muhammad peace
permission because he didn't act without
Alice panatela giving him direction on
how to move forward and so he was given
permission to leave Makkah to emigrate
to Medina and so he did and on the on
the immigration there with his with the
Sahaba named Abu Bakr his companion and
close friend they were going and they
were on the journey and there was a very
brave warrior that chased them because
there was a ransom on their heads there
was a lot of camels that were going to
be guaranteed for the person that
captured the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and brought them back to the
karesh and so he wanted that ransom and
basically on the way going there
he sank in the sand once got up kept
going sank on the sand twice chasing the
problem home with an Abu Bakr his friend
and then sank in the sand three times
and they realized you know what there's
something strange going on here I'm not
going to catch up to them and said you
know what I give up and called out to
them and the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon a buckler came to this warrior and
said yes what's going on and he said can
you please write something so that you
will recognize me should I meet you in
the future and Abu Bakr wrote something
and gave it over and and then as the
warrior was leaving the prophet muhammad
sallahu the assalam said like what would
you say if you were to see the jewelry
of the emperor of persia and the warrior
was the flabbergasted like who's gonna
even come close to that stuff and you
just walked away and it came to pass
that that warrior witnessed that event
he was able to actually wear those
bracelets I think of the the leader was
it of Persia of Persia this was a
prophecy that came true yes exactly
I made so many miracle you talk about
this in the book absolutely all of these
things that we talked about it's in the
book it's in the book okay we're out of
time tell us now where can people get
the book people can get the book on
Amazon it's available on paperback and
ebook all the proceeds go to charity to
awake I revival to nonprofit
organization and it has 12 5 out of 5
stars on Amazon and all proceeds go to
all proceeds go to charity for
charitable purposes to spread the truth
of the message and this book has also
been reviewed by Sheikh Omar Soliman and
and sections of it have been reviewed by
Sheikh Yasir Qadhi - very well
respected scholars they've reviewed the
because yes they have okay just in the
last 15 seconds what was the message of
the Prophet Mohammed it was Lyla Heil
Allah Mohammad ur Rasool Allah there is
no God except Allah and Muhammad may
peace be upon him is the messenger and
it was a message of peace that's it
thank you very much for closed Alcala
care well yeah oh thank you we'll see
you soon hopefully thank you very much
for being with us on today's show thank
you very much so that was his message la
la la la there's no deity nothing worthy
of worship except the one who made you
your Creator my Creator the creator of
this universe and everything in it
that's the same message that Jesus came
with in the law
there's no at his time God worthy of
worship except Allah except the Creator
and Jesus at that time was the messenger
and Moses this time they hate Allah
there's no God where they worship except
the critic and at that time most the
time you had to follow the messenger who
was Moses and at this time your time
today the last and final messenger is
problem Hamid peace be upon him so get
to know this man it'd be a shame we love
Jesus and you would love Muhammad but
you didn't know him now you know a
little bit about him and it'll be a
shame if you don't continue to get to
know him and it's a guarantee let me
tell you something if you're sincere
open mind open minded humble heart and
you get to know this man you will fall
in love with him because he came with
the truth he came with a message a
believable message and the proof they'll
get you to gender they'll get you to
paradise so get to know this man follow
his Sunnah his way and this is a
guarantee if you live this life
according to God's will not your desires
and you follow the last and final
messenger said to mankind you will have
Jinnah
you will have paradise and you'll avoid
the Hellfire one awful place to be at
but a wonderful place to be in is Jenna
let's strive for it follow us on the
Facebook and the Twitter and contribute
to the Deen show so we can help educate
the world so we can help get this
message out this message of peace peace
acquired by submission to the will of
the creator
now the creation we'll see you next time
insha'Allah God willing until then peace
be unto you